Move it, move it, move it, move it, move it, move it.
Hello!
Hi!
Wait, one second, one second.
I'm playing through OBS.
Sorry, everybody.
Weaver saw and then this.
Okay.
Wait, is my intro intermediate?
This is embarrassing!
Wait, okay, hold on.
Bo-e-bo-e!
Bo-e!
Bo-e-boe!
Go-so-jo-so!
Hello, hello, hello!
Get out of here!
Hello, welcome, welcome!
Sorry if I sound a little far, my mic is right here, so...
So I might sound a little far It's a bit of a scuff setup,
but...
Thank you so much!
My extra Q3-D-O-C-
Stop it!
Why am I turned so sideways, though?
Hold on.
Everything is always scuffed here, one second.
Wait, maybe it'll be okay when I'm looking at this screen.
I'm just a ghost maid.
Actually, I'm gonna move over just a little bit.
I think that's better.
A big, large, and in charge for the stream.
You can see my body, daddy, daddy.
We're doing it live.
How many times will mint flash us?
Well, maybe.
Twice or twice.
Sorry.
Well, thank you!
Thank you, Vodacu!
Thank you!
Wait, why am I turned?
Hold on, I'm gonna... We're doing it live.
We're doing it live.
You know what?
Screw it.
I'm gonna...
Yeah.
Wow.
Maybe like that is better.
I don't know why it acts so funky.
I don't know.
Why it moves me around.
Wait.
Oh wait.
Stop
that.
Big!
You're still taller though.
You're still taller than me though.
Up ease!
Shorty.
Okay, I'm bringing you down.
I'm taking you down with me.
Oh, little chat so cute.
Oh, so cute.
Oh, look at you.
Look at you.
So small.
Shall we play Warrior War before?
3D gets totally cookie.
Um, wait.
Rude!
So rude.
Uh, sorry, my computer is like all over the place.
With everything.
Okay.
Wiggly is phantom and it's my birthday tomorrow!
Shabur!
Happy birthday!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Shall we stop?
I've only played Warrior Wear one time before, so...
Uh...
Hopefully you can hear me.
Um...
And...
Six-foot dog.
I'll put you, I'll put you guys back up.
And...
Today's my birthday, Skellyroll can be bo- Wait, why am I
huge now?
Wait a second.
I keep getting bigger!
Okay, hold on.
Alright, we're here, we're here.
This is- this is fine.
I need to stop jumping around.
It makes me move.
You didn't see anything.
No, you didn't.
What's a party?
Oh, two to three.
Oh, I mean- a four.
I can read numbers.
Of course, then go with story mode.
Yes, yes, yes.
Four is like my favorite number, too.
What the heck?
Okay.
I have my joy cons.
Left-handed player hold... Oh, I hold eight.
I'm right-handed.
Be aware of your surroundings.
I have
like some decorations on.
some decorations on my fan.
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
Or number of player.
Okay, no.
Choo-choo!
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gripping?
Wait, grip with the...
Thumb on ZL.
This is the grip hole.
What?
I've never played with a grip hold before.
It's Orca's birthday today.
They are being denied a super chat.
Orca!
Sorry, I'm squeaky today too.
My voice is not so great today.
Happy birthday!
Calvo, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry about that.
if I don't see chat so much because I'm, first of all, I'm
far away from my computer.
And then also, I'm playing the game.
I'm playing the game.
So that's Z, let's grip.
Wait, what do I do with my hand?
Okay, grip.
Please use a grip hold while playing.
Okay.
Stone cold welcome.
Oh my gosh, I'm gripping it, I'm gripping it.
I hope I can have it.
I have like no headphones or anything.
My mic is, my mic setup's out, all messed up.
Out of the way, chumps!
Welcome to the island!
Please take these precious stones as a hello gift.
Diamonds, diamonds, give me, give me diamonds!
They're form stones!
Moving around with these in your hands can bring you good
luck.
Huh?
Smoking rocks, I don't want them!
So rude.
What did the bird do to you?
Oh, wow.
Minto just thinking of the controller.
What are you talking about?
What are you guys talking about?
I'm concerned.
Those who dare to approach the shrine will be punished.
What is the story?
Was there a vacation then?
Choo-choo.
Oh my gosh!
The voice from above speaks.
Hold your form stones in your hands.
Keep your arms close to your sides.
And bend your elbows at a right angle.
Your thumbs must be on top.
Okay.
The voice saw that the people were unready and had them
brace themselves for anything.
This is the origin of Choo Choo.
Choo Choo!
A form to survive an absurd endeavor.
Let's go!
Choo Choo.
Escape.
Wait, I felt that!
Okay, we escaped.
Choo Choo.
Outrace.
Okay.
Choo Choo.
Ring the bells.
Oh, oh.
Oops, my bad.
I thought I was...
It's fine, it's fine.
Choo-choo!
Go!
Stop at the station!
Nice!
Okay, I...
Extinguish.
yeah next choo-choo choo-choo oh clink oh here we go
choo-choo choo-choo open oh yeah what was that choo-choo
choo-choo creep forward Oh!
It was a red light green light!
Oh my gosh.
Booster!
Already?
Okay.
Choo-choo.
Yeah?
Yeah!
Oh!
Okay, not the electric guy.
Choo-choo.
One more, one more.
Whack!
Hang in there!
I gotta fix my camera again.
It's gonna flash everybody.
Look if it happens.
Don't look if it happens.
Don't look.
You have to avoid your eyes.
One
second.
One second.
I'm also gonna refresh.
Reset me.
Kuku!
We saw nothing yet.
As you will not see.
Ever.
Vita!
Museum!
Oh!
A ladyfriend!
I respectfully refuse to ignore the gate of heaven.
What do you mean by that?
Wait, don't...
No, you shouldn't...
What do you...
This should be fun.
I'm just leaning back.
Mermaid meet and greet.
Mermaid meet and greet!
Swim at dolphins and rays?
Wait, and mermaids too?
Mermaids.
Hey, Joe.
Mermaids, mermaids.
The laggity.
Oh my gosh, Pequod.
Am I going to be choo-choo-in again?
I'm trying to look at Mona.
Hey!
I'm right here!
Oh, Zagreb.
the grip mode let's go i'm swimming i'm swimming sky stretch
oh the voice from above wait this is kind of perform a grip
hold wait raise both hands high above your head as if
dangling from monkey bars no wait when the voice awoke and
performed the sky stretch its arms reached up through the
clouds everyone on the island could see them for miles
blocking out sunrise sky
stretch clean okay they look like the tanks look like
minions don't they night night the voice from above speaks
perform a grip hold with your hands stacked atop one another
wait hold on sorry your dominant hands should be on top The
voice saw its people were defenseless, so it gave them a
sword.
After a few mishaps, it also gave them this form, so they
knew not to hold the pointy end.
Wait, oh, I did it wrong.
Wait, I'm not ready!
Stay dry.
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, I'm not ready!
I was trying to fix myself!
Sky stretch!
Fan off!
Come on!
I'm impressed!
I'm trying to make it so that you guys can't see my panties
because I'm going upward!
Way to go!
Sky stretch!
Crawl out!
Oh my god!
Sky stretch Take both hands
Keep at it Oh, no I was trying Hit
Yeah, yeah, yeah Sky stretch Copy
That's how it's done
Close one Safety sure it's fine Keep up, okay?
No.
Why is my hand, why is my hand, okay, hold on.
Close one.
What was that?
It happened so fast.
My hands are all messed up.
Wait, wait, wait.
That was great.
You did it.
My hands are all messed up.
Here we go.
Okay, here we go.
I'm just not gonna worry about it.
Sky stretch.
Keep the flame lit.
Oh.
What's that?
No, no, no!
Fire the cannon.
I'm getting doing it!
Oh, no!
Don't do that.
Okay, we can do this.
We can do this.
This is tough.
Keep the flame lit.
I realized too I was holding it like outward rather than
inward.
Like you're supposed to grip it in a weirder way.
Fire the cannon.
Right!
No this is so messed up!
Maybe it's easier if I only have one to worry about.
Yes!
You could bring them together.
Or it didn't matter.
I didn't need to.
A job well done.
False advertising.
Hold on, Lulu.
I'll save you.
Real advertising.
She's my favorite!
I love Ashley!
She's so cute!
One second, guys.
Sorry, I gotta reset again.
Better.
I love Ashley!
Love Ashley.
Wait, okay.
Also, I'm trying to fix myself.
I don't know how to rotate myself down.
How did I fix it before?
What the heck?
Sorry.
Hey!
UGH!
This only lets me move like this, but this one's supposed to
let me move and turn and stop, and now I can't turn
them.
No.
This is...
This is bizarre, I think.
UGH!
Okay.
Now let me do this real quick.
Wait!
Why did I disappear again?
I give up, I give up, I give up.
I give up.
This is how we are.
Go back, I think the angle was right.
I don't think so.
Okay.
me better.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Nemi.
This maid is too cute.
This nurse is too cute.
Hi, Nemi.
Hello.
This game is fun.
I think you would like it.
Actually, I would like to see you play it.
Pocus Pocus.
That's what I want to see.
Caveat Imtor.
Okay, we're gonna play with Ashley.
Yippee!
She's so cute.
Don't eat mysterious fruit.
Wario Wario is so good.
Yeah!
This one uses your whole body.
It's fun.
Wait, is she gonna eat the fruit and become tiny?
Enormo size.
Status quo ante.
Make
me me again!
That was me doing magical tricks and things.
Spooky!
Hey Red, eat this.
It should help.
Okay!
Oh, grip.
Grip mode.
Alright.
Scales.
The voice from above speaks.
Perform a grip hold with both arms outstretched to the
sides.
Your thumbs must be on top.
On top.
The tilt of your body reflects the imbalance in your heart.
In order to master the scales form, one must empty one's
pockets.
Ah!
and lead to disaster.
Dominic.
Fear me.
Scale.
My arms are shining right now.
Lower what's heavier?
I don't know.
Nope.
Oh, wait.
How am I supposed to tell?
Tug of war.
Oh, tug, okay.
We're...
The voice from above speaks.
My hands are still very cross.
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't know why.
of your navel your dominant hand must be in front my
dominant hand must be one two three pull the voice taught
that everyone must pull their weight failure to do so would
be over the line their waist
tug of war
whoa that was cute Scales.
Grab and pull.
Figures.
What?
I did it though!
I did it!
I thought I would be able to...
Scales.
Choose wisely.
No!
I thought I would be able to...
Oh no, we're not gonna make it, you guys!
We're not gonna make it!
I thought that I would be able to...
The star.
Too bad.
Ah!
I thought...
Okay, one more time, one more time, one more time.
Redo!
Second chance, stand.
Do the sacred pose.
Try again.
Okay, okay, okay.
Tug of war.
Celebrate the star.
Ha!
Ah!
I'm trying!
What do you want me to do?
Soak up light.
Bravo.
Tug of war.
Um...
Cute.
I was trying to pull it.
Scales.
Decorate.
Tug of war.
Make it safe.
Oh, oh, oh.
I see.
Oh, yeah!
Speed up, speed up.
Scales.
Oh.
It didn't even give me a chance to get to the other hand.
Pierce.
Oh, sure.
Last chance.
Ashley's gonna she's gonna think I'm a loser.
Nice.
Making progress.
No, no, Graham.
Boss stage already?
Okay, okay.
What?
What is going on?
Flying?
This is not what I'm used to.
Oh god, the heart!
No!
time oh we
have the gift second chance dance do the sacred pose
again third chance dance oh my god i have to go back to this
or is this the boss stage okay okay fly Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm,
hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Oh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no...
Ah, he missed it again!
Oh, I...
I... nobody loves me in my life!
You must be cursed.
We got this, guys.
We got this!
Wow.
Why is it only picking up one ear?
Oh, please, please, please, no, no, no, no.
This way, this way, this way.
Okay, okay.
This way, this way.
Up, up, up.
Up, up, up,
up.
Wrong way, wrong way, wrong way.
No, come on.
Right, right, right.
Right here.
Run.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh my gosh.
Ah, oh god.
I just flew in and boy, are my arms tired.
Oh, you're nice and full.
Oh my gosh, my arms are tired.
Wait, what?
Moving!
What are you doing to me?
What's that face for, Ashley?
Oh my goodness, that one was tough.
Well, the communication with sensors is unstable.
Sorry I have to reset like every time.
380v2 is too cute, I think I'm losing my mind.
This one.
Oh my gosh, my arms really are tired, though.
Massage and the big cheese.
Wait, I'm excited for that one.
A curious case of cave art.
I know.
Says here, these were drawn by a real caveman.
Big cheese.
Who's that?
Yes, I've got it.
Behold my latest invention!
The time obliterator 5.0!
Obliterator?
We'll use it to observe the creation of this masterpiece.
It worked!
You're a bad dream!
Oh, wait, it's just the same thing!
It's just so mad.
If only there was something new I could draw.
Denison Ride is back, baby.
Oh my god.
Why is he doing that?
You've created a time paradox.
Okay, I'm in grip mode.
I'm gripping.
Shall we begin?
Massage.
Massage!
The voice from above speaks.
Perform a grip hold with both hands held straight out in
front of you.
Your palms should be facing down.
The voice used this form to care for those who built its
temple.
The worker's exhaustion was magically lifted.
As a result, the voice could work them even harder.
And the job was done in three days.
massage empty why is he living in there big cheese big
cheese the voice from above speaks perform a grip hold with
the palms of your hands to your hips thumbs forward then
puff out your chest
This was a form initially reserved for royals.
One day, a king did the big cheese in public.
It spread quickly amongst the people.
And as such, they're all a little cheesy.
Yes.
Wait.
Like now.
Big cheese.
Jump.
Ah!
Looks super.
Massage.
Get.
Yippee!
Okay.
Cheese.
Return curtsies.
Why she looks so dubious, though, about it.
These ones are easier.
Oh.
Trust Tether Sign.
Trust Tether Sign?
When this glyph appears, be ready to drop your form stuff.
Wait, I don't have it on!
I don't have mine on it!
Strap!
Uh-oh.
Who ever has their switch on a strap?
Oh no.
If the voice has not revealed one, then never drop your form
stone.
I'll just dangle it a little bit.
Massage.
I dropped it!
Time to hustle!
Speed up.
Big cheese.
Bump.
Every streamer runs into this problem, I believe it.
Twist.
Nice.
Big cheese.
Hand out.
Oops.
It was so fast.
Flip.
Ugh.
Skeddy.
Squid.
Big cheese.
March.
Oh, what's the big idea, buddy?
What's the big idea?
It's okay, we can just get a second chance.
Swim.
Oh, geez.
Fascinating.
That was crazy.
Big cheese.
Dodge.
Massage.
Pump.
Woohoo!
It's quick.
I can't watch.
Oh no, don't go into the tummy.
Just go down
into...
We uh...
Oh.
Wait, what is that?
Oh gosh.
Okay, I have to go down here.
What is this?
Oh, okay, okay.
All right.
No, no, no, no, no.
Dang it.
Okay.
That was so close, though.
That was so close.
One more chance.
Second chance stun!
Do the sacred pose.
I am Zen.
Nirvana.
A complete recovery.
Big cheese.
Okay, this one is tough, but it's like...
not so bad at the same time.
Pass it out.
Okay, wait, and go!
Yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Wish I didn't have to start from the very beginning, though.
Okay, that works.
This works.
And poing!
Okay.
Oh
my god.
Go, go, go!
What kind of princess has several stomachs?
Wow!
That one's so goofy.
Orbulon!
Wait, this one had like three like lifters.
Let's try it.
Oh, I forgot to...
I don't think I need to reset.
I think I'm okay.
Earthfruit is so tasty.
I want some fruit.
Thank you, goose!
Where am I?
Who am I?
Oh, so unknown.
Awesome.
I am a god.
Keep worshiping me.
What did they do to him?
What if Yaluigi had his own Mario spinoff game?
I want that.
I was hoping.
I was like, man, if I saw Yaluigi in this game, I'd be so
happy.
Wow.
Grip, ungrippin'.
We begin!
Minecraft.
Lifter.
Ooh.
Your voice from above speaks.
I have to hold it this way, not this way.
Perform a grip hold with both arms held vertically in front
of you.
Your palms should face your head.
Okay.
This form catches the strength of a mighty warrior.
The voice had intended for the barbells to be a loner.
But they worked so well that it was too intimidated to ask
for them back.
Lift her.
Oh, okay.
That was easy.
I don't feel like I did anything, but...
Gift giver.
Like this?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The voice from above speaks.
Open both hands.
Then place your form stones in them.
Place my form.
We are?
The rocks are cute in the hand like small pets.
But remember this, you too are like a small pet to the
voice.
I'm a small pet.
Gift giver.
Melt.
I'm confused.
Wait, I'm confused.
What was I supposed to do there?
Baka.
Voice from above speaks.
Perform a grip hold with your dominant hand at your nose and
the other at your rear.
Your thumbs must be at your nose and rear with the form
stones parallel to the ground.
Feathers looking slink and wind blowing back my comb.
Clucking around the island because that's all I've ever
known.
I'm clucking around the island.
This one's uncomfortable.
This one's extremely uncomfortable.
Face the wind.
Gift giver.
No!
I
just dropped it on the ground.
Gift giver.
Get candy.
That's not candy.
That's candy.
Yeah.
That ain't candy.
Candy.
Lift her.
Eat the food.
Oh, no!
That is too bad.
Why am I getting food thrown into my mouth?
Pack.
Cause it.
Gift giver.
Measure out.
Uh.
One chance remains.
Oh.
Baka.
Like a chance.
Do the sacred pose.
What is this?
Let us continue.
Look out.
It's impossible.
What is this?
Lift her.
Break the chains.
Ah!
Gift giver.
Steady.
I threw my Joy-Con.
I threw my Joy-Con on accident.
It's okay.
Play a card.
Two.
Three.
Two!
Three!
I guess the other one doesn't matter.
Play the pose.
Oh, oh.
Oh, this one.
There we go.
Oh, okay.
I don't do it myself.
Okay, just kidding.
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Reminds me of Ringfoot.
Ah, it does, right?
Put him up.
Put him up, put him...
The way they're clapping.
It's like a guy who sucks.
Somehow we lived.
Somehow we made it.
Somehow Minky survived.
He still doesn't know!
Oh no!
this fight continues remix all right we got this guys we got
this oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah bring it
down the house
Unbothered, unbothered queen.
Huh?
We landed on a...
Tour bus!
Okay, I'm in the grip.
Lifter.
Two pull-ups.
Huh!
This is fun.
Sky stretch.
Crawl out.
Oh.
Easy.
Gift giver.
Mount it all.
Ah, I'm just supposed to shake it.
Okay, okay.
Hug of war.
Ah!
Pretty good.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, sky switch.
Fan off.
Big cheese!
Return curtsies.
Excellent.
I was too early, I got to.
excited gift giver measure out what am i supposed to dump it
really fast sky stretch i stretch copy my arms were down you
guys saw you guys saw my arms were down eat the food
sweet did you saw you saw you all saw
I don't remember what pose I was supposed to be in that
further.
Big cheese.
Hand out.
Oh.
Can you keep up?
Speed up, speed up, speed up, speed up.
Speed up, speed up.
Gift giver.
Steady.
What?
It didn't even give me a chance!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
The gift.
Yeah, the heavens.
They bestow upon us.
Second chance.
Thank you.
Do the sacred pose
Boo one more time.
Boo
Stand here we go.
We're fine.
This is all good Oh, not bad We're fine.
Defend
Massage okay
You killed them.
We're fine.
Night.
Really?
Do not put actual stockings on your house.
Lift her.
Oh, it's this one again.
Okay.
Play a card.
Two.
Four?
Three!
Two!
Oh, I gotta do this.
Play the pose!
Big
cheese in your heart?
Big cheese.
Okay.
Uh, oh, this one?
Yes.
Any more?
Oh, no!
Oh, I messed up!
I messed up!
Oh!
It's a good thing we had one heart.
Look at the treasure!
Okay!
A job well done.
I'm gonna be dizzy.
One second, guys.
Let me twist around.
Let
me also reset.
Here we go.
Oh wow, I was all twisted.
I was all twisted.
Okay, let's do a few more.
Are you guys enjoying the show?
My.
Yes!
Excellent show.
But the sleeves, you look like a mantis.
No!
I'm a ghost!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
One moment, please.
The thigh ones never stay on.
I need- I need, like, a garter.
For them.
Yeah, but the sleeves, I look like a ghost.
Please, um, understand.
I look like a ghost.
Yeah.
My hands are just like this because I'm very spooky and
scary.
Oh, what did I just press?
I don't know.
Crickets!
Oh wait!
Ah, Mantis!
Cat!
Oh!
I remember this game, or not this game, but these two in
particular because I played a previous Wario where where you
could dub the you could dub the lines and it was very funny
me no cute though and I thank you for the
deep lore is it I
don't remember when I played it anyway um Jimmy Terry let's
do let's do here we go battle on flash freeze cape
remote flying was assigned to use the strap I don't I don't
even know where my scraps are, though.
I couldn't tell you where they are even.
How do you even attach it?
Where do you attach it to?
Where did the snow come from?
On a plastic piece, the bottom.
You're pretty quick on your feet to have dodged that.
It's into the radar.
Oh.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's fine.
We're fine.
It was just a one-time accident.
Squat.
Squat!
The voice from above speaks.
Perform a grip hold with your palms at your thighs.
Spread your legs and lower your hips.
Keep your hands on your thighs without letting go.
This is painful.
When the voice was angered, it held this form for threefold
things.
In doing so, the voice's wrath subsided.
What was left behind is the origin of the phrase, mountain
pass.
I have to have my head.
Squat.
Come on.
Okay.
Don't tell me to do it twice though.
Crocodile.
Is it like a...
The voice from a...
above speaks perform a grip hold with palms together and
arms held straight out your dominant hand should be on top
your hands should rest lightly atop each other we do this
out of solidarity with the items which have unusually weak
jaws crocodile unroll unroll look Ah!
Behold!
Look, Gander.
Squats.
Aw, eh.
Crocodile.
Eat too.
Cute!
Why was I drawing with my booty?
Copy.
I'm doing it!
Yes!
It hurts!
Don't fall behind!
Squeeze!
Oh, sorry!
Don't lose!
Okay, don't lose!
Oh, shoot,
shoot, shoot.
Okay, this ones are kind of hard, you guys.
Oh, okay.
Do the sacred pose.
Okay, it is pretty speedy, right?
Okay, we got this though.
Crocodile.
Yeah!
Squat.
Stomp.
Dumb.
Evaluate.
That wasn't it?
Squat.
Get dressed.
I got dressed.
You're on fire!
Crocodile!
Press the flower.
Please!
Open!
I had my arms open!
Avoid.
Oh!
Your next move is crucial!
Where's the boss stage everybody?
I don't think I'm doing so well.
Crocodile.
Okay.
Cut out the gold.
Clear a path.
Is that good enough?
Stay with it.
Great job!
Easy!
Wow, I made it somehow.
I'm impressed.
Yeah.
Just like a fellow disciple should.
It's not the voice I expected to come out of Dream.
Till next time.
Who was that?
No.
We moved me too.
Could I get a funny dance for my birthday?
Dread!
Happy birthday!
What's a funny dance?
Oh, oopsie.
Happy birthday!
Also, sorry, fire!
I missed you earlier too.
I have so many birthdays today!
Thank you for streaming, Mario, where it's awesome to see
you having fun moving and grooming on my birthday!
Happy birthday, fire!
Happy birthday to all!
Oh, my arms are starting to get tired though.
I missed some.
Some dude, thank you!
Ducky, thank you!
You saw Ariel last night.
Wait, you saw Ariel 6-7 on the entire auditorium.
Felt like you needed to know that.
Cute, Minto 3D.
If you see this, can you give us the classic Minto twirl?
Now I'm feeling really upset that she did that to you.
I'm not gonna do it for you guys, but I will do a Minto.
Okay.
Twirl!
Minto Twirl.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much, brother.
Don't know where it is.
You missed it.
Well, there's this really cool thing called the VOD.
That maybe you should check out.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
I'll do it then.
Mona cute, Ashley cute, but Minto super cute!
to cat let's do this anna you got it sis the grand parfait
adventure the grand parfait adventure
ah that carries away birthday that looks so yummy thanks for
the map guys see ya wait
where'd he go there lay off will you did you What is this?
Wait, before we start though, I'm gonna have to reset again.
So sorry.
Secret.
I'm kind of lagging a little.
Add attention.
Oh, that's just not okay.
Perform a griddle with both arms held straight down.
Do not underestimate the simpler through my my mind and body
must always be ready for it any moment you may be called
upon to accomplish the inexplicable
attention attention i feel like a fish cool moves
fashionista your voice from above speaks perform a grip hold
with your dominant hand over your shoulder thumb facing down
the other hand is at your waist its thumb should face
forward this form is very right-handed and flattering the
voice was not immune to its charms and would often show off
this form from several angles asking which was its good side
the hand placement of the joycon really matters fashionista
fashionista why
we made
it hand model hand model the voice from above speaks let go
of the left form stone hold the right form stone in your
left hand capture your right hand in the gesture window the
form stone strap should be on the bottom feeling useless and
adrift the left form stone stood awkwardly eventually the
island winds carried it off
hand model gesture when
I'm trying Look at fashionista.
Hit two.
Oh, look at how we're hitting.
Oh gosh!
Your guard was down.
We'll just, we'll just, we'll just, we just, we just
continue.
Spin and toss.
The wrong hand.
Oh my gosh!
Maybe it was the wrong hand after all!
How?
Hand model.
Screw.
Be careful!
Oh, not nice.
Never mind.
I think I was supposed to screw it in and not screw it out.
Slay.
We gotta do that again.
Oopsie.
One more time!
She's always slay!
Hang on, what are they talking about?
Do the sacred pose.
Wait, hold on.
I have to take out the sword first.
Fashionista.
Right?
Slay.
Oh.
I still have to take out the sword.
Add attention.
Roll.
Keep it together.
Oh!
Fashionista.
Find the cat.
What?
Add attention.
Hell.
I think we didn't win a single one of those guys.
Uh oh.
And I'm lagging.
Do the sacred pose.
Violent steps.
We get them next time?
Yeah!
We get them next time!
Ninja Revive!
Okay, we got this.
Uh, I gotta get the taxi.
Add attention.
Damn.
Taxi!
What are you thinking?
Hand model.
Leave to.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Wait, this is so cool, actually.
I love when you get to use, like, the little AR light on the
Joy-Con.
I think it's so fun.
Dress them.
Add attention.
You had on a helmet, so...
What?!
I'm so confused.
Pulled it out before?
Okay.
Oh, shirt!
The shirt!
Okay.
The parfait.
I forgot that was our end goal.
One cares away parfait.
Time for sweets.
Okay.
Jimmy T.
Let's dance.
Surfing surprise.
Surfing.
Surfing surprise!
Surfing!
Even fictional twins sink?
I mean that's like the thing about twins is they're always
sinking.
Ooh!
Oh
my god she's cute!
Wait!
Her?
What am I covering?
She's so cute!
Let's do it!
Sorry, I didn't mean to cover her.
What is this?
Place the form stones on a flat surface.
You don't need to crouch.
The front side should...
Okay, I don't need to crouch.
Do not remove the straps.
See the form stones.
I put them on my chair.
Respirate from human hands.
Little do they know that the silent calm is about to be
broken by the people's revels.
You should crouch.
Pounce.
Look closely.
What do I do?
Which one?
Oh, this one.
Wait, isn't that the legend?
Isn't that the legend?
Love struck.
Beaks perform a grip hold with your palms with your palms
pull in your arms with thumbs facing upwards Keep your hands
at your cheeks and don't let them slip
The voice fell deeply in love resulting in the dawn of this
like this It turned out to be more of a short-lived crush,
but the name stuck kind of goofy That was his love struck.
Love struck.
Gaze.
No.
So bang.
That went so good.
Archer.
The voice from above speaks.
Perform a grip hold with your dominant hand's palm on your
chest.
Hold the other arm straight out.
Turn your chest to the center.
as if you're drawing a bowstring.
I am...
Father, the hunt went so well today.
Yes, it's lucky for us that we've practiced the Archer form.
Parent and child return to their home as the skies above
practiced sunset form.
I am the bone of my sword.
Archer.
Sink.
Look
closely.
Flip this card.
Yes!
Archer.
Serve.
Easy.
These ones aren't so bad.
I say until it speeds up.
Catch the bird.
Aha!
Sword.
Sword?
What?
Wait, I got- I did that one!
It's my best one.
I guess my best one.
I like it.
Yay!
Archer.
My lordy.
Fish.
Watch out now.
Love strike.
Kiss the frog.
You got this.
Oh, okay.
Smash.
You know what?
This reminds me, when I twist the controllers like that, it
reminds me of a punch.
That one, two.
So that's it.
I actually have the one-two-switch game
do the sacred pose oh my god
success back to it okay archer archer alright we got this
guys real cool yeah Wait, what am I doing?
Let's just...
Oh.
Show me what you got.
Ouch.
Not done yet.
Did I mess up?
Flip it.
Oh.
Oh!
Lift.
No, I lifted it!
Played it.
What?
Oh my god.
No way.
No heckin' way.
Wait.
Wait, up, up.
Flip it.
Oh.
This guy.
Oh, played it.
I lifted.
Oh,
the other one's gonna burn.
This one's gonna burn!
Okay, we're okay.
Okay.
Wait, why are my hands, why are my hands all that stuff too?
Wait, no, no, no!
Grab it and play it.
Okay.
Right.
Grab it and play it.
I left it up?
Oh, I have to do it a bunch!
Oh yeah!
That's a- Someone cooked for...
I'm glad that one didn't have like a real time...
Uh...
A real time timer.
Groovy!
Dribble in space!
Wait, hold on, I'm gonna reset again so that maybe I
hopefully am not...
Very
cool!
Dribble drive!
Making waves!
do a little laggy sorry this is just a life dribble my
friend wake up buddy we've got trouble look at where we are
i guess we're racing now well i'm on it three
gonna win oh my grip all right button sign button sign when
this cliff appears press buttons on your form stone okay the
form stone has many buttons yes which of them should you
press only your heart can tell you that okay I think I think
it will tell me, maybe.
Choo-choo!
Ah!
That's fun!
Answer!
Oh, oops!
Oh!
Choo-choo.
Count them.
I was scared for a second!
I entered the call.
Onion wouldn't...
Count.
Plug leaks.
Wait, that's so fun!
Nice!
That way that's so fun!
She denied my call!
Grab!
Wait.
Choo-choo!
Click out!
Nice!
Now we're so close.
That's neat.
Didn't it?
Oh, I didn't even need to press that.
My hand slips.
Okay.
Wow, the scales.
It's been a while.
We never screwed a chance.
My hands are sweaty.
There.
Do the sacred pose.
Maybe ectoplasm.
Look at that.
Let's get moving.
All right.
We got this.
This one, we're spraying the gold.
That's it.
Spray clean.
Nice.
Archer.
Learn it.
Play it.
Stop in the zone.
Oh.
I did it strong.
Take your child's hand.
I like how they're like, this one's your child.
Where was this child?
Take the child!
Take a child!
Easy.
Suck it up.
Come on!
You got this kid?
She can't suck!
Massage.
Shoot!
Whoa!
I'm
doing it.
I'm doing it.
Woo!
Ow!
It might be a flying toilet.
It might be a toilet robot.
It might be a skibbity robot.
It might be...
It might be.
Oh, I think they're gonna make it.
Thank you so much 3D.
Thank you, CD!
I knew this hippo was gonna win.
Everybody else went the wrong way!
Any minute now, I can smell that finish line.
Nice, nine bolt.
What's in the...
Oh, the museum, okay.
I'm guessing this is ones that we could do before.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
All the forms we've learned.
Like this one.
Hold on.
Archer.
Learn it.
Play it.
One more time!
Learn it!
Oh, she is extra cute!
Play
it!
One more time!
Play it!
Do-do-do-do-do- Do-do-do-do-do- Do-do-do!
We didn't get a single one, you guys.
Do, do, do, do, do.
We didn't get a single one.
There's so many of you haven't gotten.
I think though I'm gonna call it here.
The head strap is starting to give me a slight headache, so
I hope you guys don't mind.
I know we didn't get super, super far into the game, but...
I still had a lot of fun.
volcano at least, but...
But thank you guys for...
for the blur you were.
I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys did too.
Wait, before we go.
It's worth waking up for him to get to the stream.
Thank you, Wiggletuber!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Cool to sleep, David.
Thank you for a fun 3D stream on this very cool day.
I know!
I just want to put on my Oh my jacket, I'm so cold!
Boobius, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I can't see it, so thank you!
Um...
We're in the void.
We're voiding, we're in the void.
We're in the void now!
Um...
Wait, where did I go?
No.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for the ultra cute stream today.
Can we get 3D?
MINTO?
No.
No, thank you.
Rikitanku!
Wait, I want to do...
Hold on.
There we go.
Okay.
Well, folks, we had a grand old time today.
But it's time to say goodbye.
And I will see you in the next one.
That's all, folks.